With the supermarket formula, only enough parts were produced in the first phase...
...to replace what was used in the second, and so on.
This is where the just-in-time system really took shape.
Toyota was able to eliminate much of the waste in Ford's system,...
...making smaller numbers of parts to be used when it needed them,...
...allowing the company to operate on a tighter budget.
Ohno and Toyoda also noticed that American car companies...
...were still employing many of Henry Ford's early production techniques.
They kept operations at full tilt in order to maximize efficiencies of scale...
...but then had to repair defective cars after they rolled off the line.
Ohno believed this caused more problems and didn't encourage workers or machines...
...to stop making the mistake,...
...so he placed a cord above every station which any worker...
...could pull to stop the entire assembly if they spotted a problem.
The whole team would work on it, to prevent it from happening again.
As teams identified more problems, the number of errors began to drop dramatically.